alors que Harol Lebel vient tout juste
d'obtenir sa libération conditionnelle
la victime dans cette affaire
d'agression sexuelle a demandé au
tribunal de lever l'ordonnance de nos
publications qui protègent son identité
et elle souhaite que la levée ne soit
effective qu'à partir du 18 avril
c'est-à-dire le jour de la sortie d'un
documentaire sur son expérience dans le
système judiciaire le juge dit qu'il a
l'intention d'accorder la requête mais
il a quand même pris en délibéré alors
pour parler de tout ça on accueille
guylan Bachant qui est avocat civilise
alors c'est assez habituel si on peut
dire en tout cas de plus en plus
régulier qui est des victimes qui
veulent parler publiquement mais là on
demande la levée de l'ordonnance avec un
délai de presque un mois c'est ça le
côté inhabituel honnêtement oui j'ai
pratiqué quelques années en droit des
médias personnellement moi j'ai jamais
vu ça vous avez raison on avait vu des
femmes demandées que tout à coup on
dévoile leur identité parce qu'elle
voulait sortir un livre un documentaire
vous vous souvenez vous avez découvert
l'affaire les sorellicules elles ont été
devant la cour on a dit d'accord vous
pouvez dévoiler votre nom vous êtes
majeurs maintenant et quelques mois plus
tard le livre paraissait même chose Léa
Clermont Dion récemment elle est allée
voir le juge elle a dit maintenant je
veux que mon nom soit public et quelques
mois plus tard il y avait un
documentaire mais la façon et c'est un
média quoi on savait déjà les identités
mais la façon que vous me décrivez pas
mal plus créative oui en effet et la
question que les gens se posent et nous
pose habituellement c'est est-ce que
c'est toujours accordé où il y a des
circonstances où les juges pourraient
être plus réticents par exemple oui
théoriquement là c'est pas
nécessairement toujours accordé j'ai en
tête un quatre é brièvement c'est un
jeune il était sous DPJ devenu majeurs
il veut apparaître dans un documentaire
à face découverte qu'on connaisse son
nom et le juge avait décidé qu'il était
trop fragile pour qu'on fasse ça alors
que ces deux camarades de même scénario
là on a documentariste avait pu dévoiler
l'identité mais il faut le dire en
général c'est accordé aux femmes
victimes d'agression sexuelle dit en des
mots beaucoup plus savants là les juges
disent qui suis-je pour juger parce que
les femmes ont fait ça pour les protéger
si elle ne veulent plus de cette
protection ben c'est elle qui décide là
encore Nathalie Simard le juge avait
même dit la seule personne qui peut se
plaindre dans le fond c'est une
établissement
et on n'est jamais obligé de dire
pourquoi de justifier on n'est pas
obligé de montrer qu'on le fait pour des
des valeurs morales élevées non mais en
général les femmes expliquent pourquoi
c'est bien accueilli il faudrait
théoriquement là que ce soit vraiment
contre leur public leur raison j'en
connais pas de cas et on va danser des
décisions là aussi parler souvent de
liberté d'expression parce que les
femmes ont un droit de parole après sur
ce qu'elles ont vécu oui effectivement
je pense que c'est Nathalie Simard qui
disait je veux avoir le droit de donner
ma version parce que lui parle parlant
de vie culture mais moi je peux jamais
rien dire parce qu'évidemment elle avait
pas le droit de se dévoiler alors ça
c'était un des exemples dans les
affaires d'agression sexuelle c'est sûr
que on demande le DPCP demande une
ordonnance mais ça lie ça lit pas juste
les médias si tout le monde qui est
assujetti à ça absolument tout le monde
n'importe qui qui écrirait par exemple
sur les réseaux sociaux Facebook Twitter
Instagram il contreviendrait à
l'ordonnance d'ailleurs vous souvenez
dans l'affaire de la fillette de Granby
son nom son image partout même la
nécrologie Isabelle avait fait un petit
cafouillage et le juge avait rappelé
assez avec force il fallait tout le
monde respecter ce genre d'ordonnance là
il y avait pas eu de conséquences parce
que j'ai l'impression je sais pas j'ai
pas interview oui les procureurs mais je
me dis pourquoi ajouter à leur
accablement en les accusant d'outrage au
tribunal mais il y aurait pu en avoir
également tout à fait tout à fait c'est
pas un lieu où il y a plus de loi qui
régissent mais dans les faits là c'est
toujours plus compliqué des fois bon ce
matin le juge dit qu'il avait
l'intention de la rendre cette
ordonnance de la levée l'ordonnance mais
il a pas rendu l'addition il attend au
18 avril pour expliquer la mécanique
alors en gros il pense qu'il veut
prévenir les erreurs qui pourraient se
produire parce que techniquement il
aurait pu la levier aujourd'hui tout à
fait c'est ce qu'on voit là
habituellement
comme sphab en droit criminel de faire
ça une séquence je vais l'accorder mais
ça aura lieu 18 avril à 9h lorsque un
reportage ou un documentaire va sortir
ce qui a voulu dire c'est
qu'effectivement chez les chez les
publics ou même chez certains médias on
pourrait dire est-ce qu'elle est élevée
aujourd'hui mais ou non ou le 18 alors
il va passer une mécanique mais
honnêtement j'ai réfléchi depuis ce
matin en lisant ça dans les journées
vous me demandez de regarder les nuages
puis de voir quel animal
mais je vois pas moi personnellement de
mécanique particulière à part de
rappeler de respecter l'ordonnance
jusqu'au 18 ans alors il préfère
attendre le 18 comme ça tout sera clair
pour tout le monde tout à fait merci
beaucoup guylan je vous en prie pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI